المتحدث باسم الامين العام للامم المتحده
ان قوافل المنظمه الدوليه لم تواجه اي
مشاكل عند مرورها عبر معبر باب السلامه
الحدودي لايصال المساعدات الانسانيه
للسوريين واكد دجاريك ان الامم المتحده
تعمل على تقييم حاله معبر الراعي وانها
متفائله بشان استخدامه بشكل سلس وسريع
أني
لم نواجه اي مشكلات في الواقع سارت الامور
على ما يرام هذا الصباح لدينا فريق تقييم
في الموقع الثالث معبر الراعي لمعرفه مدى
السرعه التي يمكننا من خلالها تشغيله
لكننا متفائلون جدا بان الامور ستتحرك
بسرعه كما قلنا تم استخدام الكثير من هذه
المعابر من قبل منظمات اغاثه غير تابعه
للامم المتحده والطرق المؤديه اليها في
حاله افضل من طريق معبر باب الهوى